in this low-lying car I drive in I've
been noticing something lately when I'm
sitting in traffic I either can't see
past the cars in front of me or the cars
around me are towering over me and it
turns out there's a big reason for that
the production of Passenger cars like
sedans and wagons for sale in the US has
been in free fall since 1975 and in
their place has been the steady growth
in the production of SUVs last year SUVs
and trucks made up 80 percent of all new
car sales compare that to 52 percent in
2011. the fact that Americans like big
cars probably won't shock anyone they
are everywhere even in my parking scarce
neighborhood in Brooklyn
but the reasons behind this
transformation are more than just
cultural it all goes back to a 50 year
old policy that would kick off a huge
shift in the way U.S cars are designed
[Music]
so I'm driving from my home in Brooklyn
New York to a beach in Rhode Island for
a summer vacation and along the way I'm
going to piece together why big cars
took over America
New York was the 45th state to
officially succumb to the Takeover of
SUVs and trucks in 2014. according to
this Washington Post analysis Alaska was
the first state to go big car dominant
in 1988. so I'm wondering if you have
any advice for things I should look out
for while I'm on the road anywhere that
you stop count the number of SUVs versus
the number of Passenger cars hey I'm the
Costco parking lot filled with SUVs one
two three
four five six seven
eight
nine ten eleven SUVs in a row I think
that is my new record
so once you learn about how much big
cars dominate the road it's like you
can't unsee it people have lots of
reasons for choosing a big car and
certainly the infrastructure in the US
supports that choice unlike a lot of
other countries our built environment
revolves around cars we have wide roads
and wide plentiful parking spaces and
homes with plenty of parking I arrived
in Connecticut a state that succumbed to
light truck dominance in 2016 and pulled
into a rest stop where I interviewed
Thomas bochinek who was on a
cross-country road trip with his wife
it's very comfortable okay the drive
well I think the bigger the car the more
you have a feeling of security you know
the smaller the car you know
but more likely I think about getting
into an accident being hurt it has no
trouble pulling this almost 7 000 pound
trailer
is one deterrent for big cars is that
they cost so much to fill up with gas
but due to low taxes on gas in the U.S
fuel is extremely cheap compared to
other countries
but there's another overlooked bias
towards big cars related to why SUVs
exist in the first place
in the 1970s there was a shortage of
foreign oil in the U.S 1973 dramatized
U.S dependence on foreign oil so the U.S
government set rules for automakers to
start making cars more fuel efficient to
lessen our dependence on the whims of
the global oil Market by 1985 new cars
had to get 27.5 miles per gallon or
roughly double their fuel efficiency
these new rules applied to cars like
sedans and station wagons under a
category known as passenger cars but
there were types of vehicles the US
government Exempted from these rules
things like pickup trucks which everyday
drivers weren't really driving at the
time and the idea was if these are
working vehicles used by you know
Farmers construction Crews companies
that are hauling Freight Those Vehicles
need to be able to do their job without
being choked by emissions controls and
without being held to unrealistic fuel
economy standpoints so passenger cars
got one set of strict rules and this
other category called light trucks got
another set of more relaxed standards
this regulation created an incentive for
car makers to transform light trucks
into a vehicle for everyday use put in a
radio lots of cargo space and comfy
seats and voila that's how we got the
SUV okay girls we're off in our new Jeep
Cherokee behind that classic appearance
it's rugged and Powerful an automaker
needs to spend less money and less time
on fuel economy and Emissions
Improvement if they're making and
selling an SUV because it falls under a
category that is less stringently
regulated we had the Wagoneer but it was
very low volume very bespoke very
expensive it's only a very few people
bought it people lived in Manhattan
would go to The Hamptons or go to
Northern New York state to go skiing and
that's how the SUV started off life this
is Ralph gels head of design at
stalantis a conglomerate of car
companies that includes Jeep one of the
early SUVs was the Chevy Blazer built on
the frame of the Chevy the S10 truck
this is the traditional definition of an
SUV if it was built on the frame of a
truck and to meet the legal definition
of a light truck it had to have some
clearance angles and dimensions just
right taking a utilitarian vehicle and
turning it into a almost a premium
luxury device that happened to be
utilitarian then comes the Grand
Cherokee the Jeep Grand Cherokee was
built the way Passenger cars are in one
piece or unibody these two types of car
constructions frame based and unibody
today form the distinction between
traditional SUVs and the new
increasingly popular category of
crossover they're more efficiently
packaged you don't have the frame the
Grand Cherokee was part of the early
success story of SUVs in the 90s and
2000s one that continues today
this bias towards light trucks is why a
company like Volkswagen which Once Sold
primarily Passenger cars has
discontinued a lot of them today like
the Passat in favor of SUVs and
Crossovers and they've stopped producing
all of their wagons including the Jetta
wagon I'm in and a company like Ford has
stopped producing all of their passenger
cars except for the iconic Mustang
okay I'm gonna see if anyone at this car
dealership will talk to me Buick was
always car really those mostly sedans
and then just with the market shift we
actually don't even sell a Buick Sedan
anymore they don't even make a Buick
Sedan it's all it's all acid crossovers
when was the last time you guys carried
like a passenger car uh it was like
three or four years ago and
like one to a hundred of us you know
SUVs we're here to sell cars we want to
sell what people want if they were here
people didn't want them I'm glad they're
not here anymore you know so this chart
starts to make a lot more sense 1975 was
the year these fuel economy standards
for stands and wagons were passed the
same ones that didn't apply as strictly
to SUVs and trucks it's a little bit of
a chicken and egg thing because the
automakers have been marketing SUVs more
preferentially than passenger cars
they've been putting more research and
development into creating more models
that fit into the SUV category and
they've made it so that it's an easier
decision to get into an SUV than it is
to get into a passenger car as of 2016
our fuel economy standards shifted
vehicles are still separated by the
stricter standard for passenger cars and
looser standard for light trucks but
within those categories there are more
breakdowns Regulators multiply a car's
wheelbase length by its width to get a
footprint and larger cars within each
category get weaker rules that means
that car makers are not only
incentivized to phase out passenger cars
in their Fleet but they are pushed to
make each category bigger the Toyota
Camry got both longer and wider and the
Toyota RAV4 did too I've now reached
Rhode Island the very last state in the
country to go light truck dominant we
have started the inevitable transition
to electric vehicles but if you're still
talking about a larger vehicle with
higher ground clearance that's heavier
and taller it's still going to be less
energy efficient whether it's an
electric car or an internal combustion
powered car one sobering impact of big
cars is the threat it poses to
pedestrians one study found that
replacing the growth in SUVs with cars
would have averted over a thousand
pedestrian deaths people on foot get hit
higher and in more vulnerable regions
when hit by an SUV or a truck rather
than a passenger car
before hitting the beach I stopped at my
friend Kevin Wright's house he's bucked
the SUV Trend and drives a Honda Fit a
car that was discontinued in 2020. we
had our daughter about 17 months ago
it's just kind of making sure that
everybody has enough space to be
comfortable as well as being safe it
gets good gas mileage and thinking about
long-term you know climate change is
happening what can we do to minimize our
carbon footprint as much as we can so we
were thinking about a second car you
know maybe getting an SUV in that
situation but ultimately decided to kind
of go the other direction and and got an
e-bike
have arrived
[Music]
even though we're in Rhode Island which
was the last holdout for SUV dominance
there is still a lot of SUVs here
[Music]
I'm curious if you think there's any
political will or urgency to change this
trend towards bigger cars you know
that's something that's uh that has
environmental concerns it's something
that has economic concerns with how much
we are reliant on oil it also has to do
with safety you know pedestrian safety
cyclist safety so there is a desire
among younger people and more
politically active people to try to make
it so that an SUV is not the default
vehicle choice for American families the
U.S is unlikely to become a small car
country anytime soon but this dramatic
transition to big cars wasn't just about
consumer Choice it was enabled by policy
choice so if we want our roads to look
different we could try and start there
thank you
foreign